former National Security Advisor John
Bolton is hitting back at President
Trump who accuses bolton of publishing
classified information for profit bolton
says he cleared everything in his new
book the room where it happened it was
released yesterday by Simon & Schuster a
division of Viacom CBS CBS Evening News
anchor and managing editor Norah
O'Donnell spoke with Bolton about some
of his explosive claims you labeled the
President of the United States a danger
to the Republic
that's quite a charge how was he
dangerous well I think in the national
security field his decision-making is
not anchored in any discernable
philosophy he has no grand strategy if
the president is such a danger to the
Republic you left office nine months ago
why wait so long to let the country know
that well I think it's important to try
and explain what I saw in as
comprehensive a fashion as I could
you've been called a liar the Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo said that you were
left out of meetings because he was
leaking or he would twist things or he
lied yeah well Mike and I obviously have
a substantial disagreement here because
I think his department was the ace of
aces and the government for leaking
things his he has made a decision which
is certainly his to make to tie his
political future to Donald Trump I think
that's what he continues to do I feel
sorry for him for doing that but
obviously I'm not going to change his
mind how would you compare the Trump
White House to previous Republican
administrations you worked in I had
never seen anything like when you go out
sailing and say well we'll know where
we're going when we get there which is
what happens all too often in the Trump
administration that that's where it can
be dangerous for the country on North
Korea
I mean president rump is the first
sitting president to meet with the North
Korean leader and the president touts
this is one of his great foreign policy
successes is it a success no it's a it's
a manifest failure Trump believes it's
sitting down with anybody
doesn't confer legitimacy on the other
side doesn't give them anything
I think that's dead wrong and I think in
international affairs countries all over
the world were stunned that he was
prepared to reward the North Koreans for
their intransigent unacceptable behavior
after three meetings with Kim jong-un we
got nowhere who was the safer choice for
America's commander-in-chief President
Trump or Joe Biden I'm not going to vote
for either one and it's a it's a
question of of apples and oranges it's a
very bad election from my point of view
at the presidential level what I'm going
to do is write in the name of a
conservative Republican leader well the
writing is not gonna win that's true my
plan is to hope for a miracle
Nora joins us now from Washington good
morning Nora you also pressed mr. Bolton
on the claims that he heard president
Trump plead with the Chinese president
to help him win the 2020 election what
did what did Bolton say about that well
there's clearly a lot more to this story
that we don't know already Democrats
tried to impeach the President on
inviting foreign interference in a u.s.
election by asking Ukraine for a favor
in Bolton's book he seems to suggest
that President Trump asked Xi to help
him win the 2020 election so I asked the
former national security adviser
directly what was the explicit ask was
there an explicit ask from President
Trump and he said he couldn't talk about
it
Boulton said because of the vetting
process he had to remove some of the
specifics from the book we know that
President Trump said hey buy more of our
agricultural products soy beans etc but
the question is what specific ask was
there and I think this is a really big
story Anthony because in the
intelligence officials that I've talked
to previous to this interview are very
concerned about foreign interference in
the twenty20 election not just from
Russia but also from China China has
huge cyber cyber capabilities they're an
economic powerhouse no doubt and so I
think that's a big question mark
certainly as we follow this election for
the net for the coming months yeah and
the latest polls Norah have the
than trailing in the election what did
mr. Bolton say about the ability missed
the president's ability to possibly
handle defeat in November well look
president Trump has already suggested
that some elections are rigged he's
raised questions about the legitimacy of
mail-in ballots even though he votes by
mail as does most of the White House
staff and those on his campaign and so
the question is will president Trump
contest the election in November and he
said that he probably will and that
sometimes contesting election is
legitimate he worked Bolton worked on
the George W Bush campaign but in this
particular instance he said he would
hope that if if Trump lost the
Republican Party would tell Trump that
he needed to leave office as they did
with Richard Nixon pretty stunning
pretty stunning all right Norah
O'Donnell Thank You Norah